hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
for tonight's Halloween event has begun
allowing us to grab some cosmetic items
over the next few weeks
if you're having trouble dancing in
front of gargoyles for the first
challenge then I've got your hop back
here's all 9 locations that I've found
so far but you'll only need 5 let's do
this down in the bottom left corner of
the map a top of the mountain is the
first gargoyle he's taking a dump come
on we've all been there
he's just above flush factory where the
north at Viking Valhalla is another
gargoyle which can be easily missed as
it blends in so well he's in the
longhouse sitting at the head of the
table open the castle overlooking
Haunted Hills is the most obvious spot
for a gargoyle and there he is
sitting downstairs in the tombs if you
grab a rift from the castle you can drop
directly on another gargoyle this one is
over by the quarry shaped like an
umbrella near the motel it's hidden
behind a few breakable items above
wailing woods you'll find a secret a a
meeting for NPC's in the game the
gargoyle has joined the scarecrow and
the teddy bear here make your way into
the ruins at tomato temple in the center
is Gary the gargoyle
[Music]
good ol Gary just to the right
tilted towers and south of Kevin and the
island is another gargoyle on the
hilltop over in retail row and inside
the Halloween shop you'll find another
gargoyle hiding in plain sight and the
last one I found is below the track on
the east side of the map
it's almost out to sea on an outcrop of
rocks it's a little dangerous grabbing
this one but you shouldn't be shot in
the back whilst dancing here there we go
done and dusted it's been a pleasure
still around anyone still here right
sausage in the comments and I'll find
you and thank you for staying till the
end
I am Adam from Playstation grenades spin
a pleasure I'll see you next time